me gradué de la universidad,
trabajé para Ford Motor Company durante varios años,
luego trabajé en la Iglesia de Jesucristo de los Santos de los Últimos Días
y regresé a Salt Lake City.
En ese empleo tuve la oportunidad de que me asignaran
al refugio más grande para personas sin hogar del estado
para ayudarlos a desarrollar y mejorar
sus capacidades financieras y de gestión.
Mientras estaba allí, vi un nuevo enfoque
para tratar con personas sin hogar
y drogadictos.
Se llamaba el modelo de reducción de daños,
y consistía en repartir agujas limpias y condones.
Y pensé: "Sí que es una idea estúpida".
(Risas)
"Eso los va a alentar a continuar con ese comportamiento.
Solo díganles que paren".
Varios años después, leí algunos de los primeros planes a 10 años
para terminar con la carencia de hogar
promovido por el gobierno federal.
Mientras leía esos planes, pensé,
"¡Pfft! Esto no es realista.
No puedes acabar con la falta de vivienda.
Hay demasiadas decisiones personales y factores fuera de nuestro control".
Mi perspectiva cambió, sin embargo,
cuando asistí a una conferencia en 2003,
donde aprendí la razón detrás del plan a 10 años.
Primero fue esta pequeña población del grupo de personas sin hogar
que era un 15 % y era muy costosa.
Eso tenía sentido
para un estado conservador como Utah.
La segunda idea fue conocer de este programa Housing First,
o vivienda muy asequible.
Había una agencia en la ciudad de Nueva York
que había estado invitando a personas sin hogar con enfermedades mentales
a pasar directamente de la calle a la vivienda.
Y también se les permitió continuar usando drogas y bebiendo,
como nosotros en nuestros hogares.
Además, se les ofrecieron servicios, --no era obligatorio usarlos--,
de trabajadores sociales
para ayudarlos a adaptarse a su nueva forma de vivir
y a estabilizar sus vidas.
Estaban usando el modelo de reducción de daños.
Y a pesar de mis bajas expectativas iniciales al escuchar sobre este modelo,
estaban teniendo una tasa de éxito sorprendente:
el 85 % todavía estaban alojados después de 12 meses.
La tercera idea
era la importancia de desarrollar una relación de confianza.
Debido al abuso que estas personas han tenido
durante la mayor parte de sus vidas,
casi no confían en nadie,
y las agujas limpias y los condones y la vivienda asequible
era un medio para comenzar a desarrollar una relación de confianza.
Vital.
Mientras volvía a casa de esta conferencia,
sentado en el avión mirando por la ventanilla,
me di cuenta de que mi comprensión y perspectiva sobre la falta de vivienda
estaba cambiando.
Y mientras miraba por la ventanilla,
este sentimiento y pensamiento muy fuertes vinieron a mí
que si hay algún estado en la unión
que podría terminar con la carencia crónica de hogar,
era el estado de Utah,
porque hay un sentimiento subyacente
y el deseo y la voluntad de colaborar para servir a nuestros vecinos,
incluidos aquellos sin hogar.
Una nueva visión me fue aclarando sobre cómo se podría hacer esto.
Quienes asistieron a la conferencia dijeron:
"Sí, estos modelos funcionarán en Utah".
Pero cuando volvimos a casa, hubo muchos que dijeron:
"Nah, eso no va a funcionar. No tendrán éxito aquí".
Pero hubo, sin embargo, una organización de vivienda asequible
que estuvo dispuesta a construir nuestras primeras 100 unidades.
Pero les preocupaba tener a 100 personas crónicamente sin hogar
en un solo lugar.
Para afrontar esa preocupación, decidimos crear un piloto
para probar esa idea mientras construíamos las primeras 100 unidades.
Utilizaríamos las unidades existentes diseminadas por Salt Lake City.
Luego debatimos:
¿Deberíamos seleccionar personas sin hogar que funcionaran bastante bien
o los más desafiantes que pudiéramos encontrar?
Y aquí es donde entraron en juego mis antecedentes en el rancho.
Por entonces, mi madre cocinaba nuestras comidas
y calentaba el agua para nuestro baño semanal
en una estufa de leña y carbón.
Y después de cortar leña para esa estufa por muchos años,
había aprendido a cortar primero el extremo más grande del tronco,
cuando yo tenía la mayor energía.
Decidimos usar el enfoque "primero el extremo grande",
y seleccionamos a los 17 más desafiantes que pudimos encontrar,
personas difíciles, crónicamente sin hogar,
porque sabíamos que aprenderíamos más de ellos.
Veintidós meses después,
los 17 todavía estaban alojados,
incluyendo Keta,
quien hoy, 11 años después,
está durmiendo en su propia cama
y está sobria.
Al final de este piloto, uno de los trabajadores sociales dijo:
"Solíamos debatir en nuestras clases universitarias
qué teoría de trabajo social era la más efectiva.
Ahora nuestra teoría de trabajo social es:
cualquier cosa necesaria para mantenerlos alojados".
Nos convertimos en creyentes,
y construimos cientos de unidades en los siguientes 10 años,
llevando a la reducción de nuestra población crónicamente sin hogar
a nivel estatal al 91 %.
Ahora, ¿quiénes son las personas sin hogar?
Muchas personas solo quieren que se vayan, desaparezcan,
que no alteren sus vidas
A través de este proceso de 10, 11 años, obtuve muchas ideas
de por qué las personas se vuelven sin hogar.
Una de esas ideas me vino hace unos años
cuando estaba visitando con nuestro equipo médico.
Son nuestros trabajadores de primera línea
que visitan en la calle a los sin hogar y a las prostitutas
para verificar su salud médica.
Uno del equipo comentó
que 8 de las prostitutas habían dado a luz a 31 niños
que se habían quedado bajo tutela del estado.
También compartieron que algunos de los proxenetas eran sus maridos,
y peor aún,
sus padres.
Estas prostitutas,
en su adolescencia tardía, 20 años, principios de los 30,
se esperaba que ganaran suficiente dinero al día para mantener
una adicción a la heroína de cien dólares al día,
sus gastos de vida
y su chulo.
Y con el sexo sin protección, les pagaban más,
y predeciblemente, esto llevaba a embarazos.
Los niños nacidos en estas circunstancias muchas veces terminan sin hogar.
Y no es útil mirar a los nacidos bajo esas circunstancias,
o un padre que hace que su hijo sea un drogadicto a los siete años,
o una generación de bebés nacidos por adicción a las drogas,
y no sentir algo de desesperación.
Yo creo que todas las personas tienen valor,
no importa quién eres.
Y no es útil mirar a alguien con este comienzo en la vida
y culparlo por donde está.
(Aplausos)
Nadie crece diciendo: "Mi objetivo en la vida es llegar a ser un sin hogar".
Y esa es la belleza de la reducción de daños y el modelo Housing First.
Reconoce las complejidades de los diferentes factores
que pueden formar una vida humana.
Estos modelos encuentran a las personas donde están,
no donde estamos nosotros
o donde creemos que deberían estar.
El piloto que hicimos con nuestros 17 nos enseñó muchas lecciones.
Cuando la gente ha estado viviendo en la calle por muchos años,
al volver a la vivienda
requiere aprender muchas cosas.
Y Donald
nos enseñó algunas de estas lecciones de transición.
Su trabajador social le preguntó por qué no había subido el calor
en su frío apartamento.
Donald dijo: "¿Cómo haces eso?".
Le mostró cómo usar un termostato.
El trabajador social también observó
que estaba calentando los fríjoles en la lata en la estufa,
como lo había hecho en las fogatas por muchos años.
Le mostró cómo usar ollas y sartenes.
También aprendimos que tenía una hermana que no había visto en 25 años,
que pensó que estaba muerto.
Ella se puso feliz de saber lo contrario,
y pronto se reconectaron.
Cientos de personas como Keta y Donald están alojadas
y reconectadas con sus familias.
Además, muchas de nuestras comunidades están incurriendo
en menores costos de servicios de emergencia.
He aprendido una y otra vez
que cuando escuchas la historia de alguien con el corazón abierto,
caminas en sus zapatos con ellos,
no puedes evitar amarlos y cuidarlos
y querer servirlos.
Es por eso que estoy comprometido
en continuar brindando esperanza y apoyo a nuestros ciudadanos sin hogar,
a quienes considero mis hermanos y hermanas.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)